oh well okay okay okay
[Music]
hello I'm Hannah Hart and welcome to
edible history the show where we
reminisce on recipes times dismissed
today will be unraveling the history of
the ravioli when I think of ravioli
I think of delicate pillows stuffed with
delicious surprises but where did these
pasta pockets come from
while most pasta dishes mix and mingle
amongst their toppings ravioli keeps its
flavors hidden away in mystery how did
this clandestine pasta get it started to
fill me in on the history of ravioli I'm
chatting with culinary historian and
author can you tell me a little bit
about the history behind who was
actually making the ravioli and it was
intended to be for banquets
that's kind of funny when you picture
somebody walking out a feast being like
thank you everyone for being here
tonight ravioli so can you tell us a
little bit about the recipe we'll be
making today
[Music]
he was a chef that worked for a very
famous Duke and hoops principal advisors
and says was a meat ravioli it would
have been served in a rich meat raw
cheese grated on top
that sounds pretty delicious I also know
how he says sweet slices without giving
you details in that recipe would have
been sugar spice Wow any other pro tips
you can share with me as I go and make
this beautiful ravioli well as you go
down the instructions you're gonna
notice that it says how long to cook in
the kitchen so you had to tell ships
something else is a reference and this
recipe says to cook it as long as it
takes to see two of the Lord's Prayer
England they didn't have a measuring
tape they were no standardized what's an
inch or centimeter and in this case it's
Wow
okay step one get a chestnut
so today's recipe comes from the year
1465 and the book libro de Arte cookie
Nadia the recipe itself is called
ravioli in tempo de carne which means
ravioli in meat time
what's meat time we're about to find out
the first step is to take 1/2 libra of
aged cheese and a little of another fat
cheese first things first
our 1/2 libra of parmesan it is actually
and for our another fat cheese we're
using ricotta ricotta
I gotta ricotta boom badda ricotta y
nada
you got a ricotta next we take our beef
cheek that's a big cheek and we'll be
putting it in boiling water
goodnight beef cheek next we'll be
combining our Don tada nice herbs what
are nice herbs well your guess is as
good as ours and our guest is very good
because we talked to an expert our nice
herbs our parsley marjoram and mint so
we're gonna muddle these all together so
they blend together really well
parsley marjoram what is marjoram yeah
just like so and lastly mint for those
of you who have amateur gardens at home
watch out for mint they're invasive
really it just will kill all your others
this is where we start to really put the
love in
there you go and now it's turned into
this kind of fine paste of tastes mostly
parsley I ain't got comes through the
strongest so we take our herbs and we
add them to our Bowl now it's time to
add our first set of spices in this case
clove Dada ginger and pepper our next
step is optional but listen to this and
if you add the chopped breast of a cape
on so much the better
what's a cape on a cape on is a
castrated male chicken what the cluck
chicken about yeah it doesn't really
it's interesting it doesn't really smell
like a chicken you know it smells
different it tastes more like Turkey
than chicken delicious now we take our
handfuls of minced Cape on and transfer
them to our Bowl and now it's time to do
the same thing to our beef cheek oh it's
shrunk
now mince you know in this mincing
process I gotta say that our beef cheek
now bears a strong resemblance to a wet
cat food and the smell isn't far off
mixed with some Cape on these herbs some
ginger clove and pepper
not to mention two kinds of cheese I
really don't know how this is gonna add
up scoop oh good it just all kind of
congeals back together now that we've
got all our ingredients it's time to
combine
and that's it for our filling so time to
make the dough let's DotA's so we're
gonna put all of our flour onto the
table next we're going to be making a
well a well is basically something that
you see pasta makers do quite easily but
Hanna's have a very difficult time
mastering okay okay now incorporate the
eggs with the flour using a fork while
somehow not destroying your well it's
going really well
gently yeah Oh God
okay oh lord I will be right back
so that didn't go so well but we have
achieved what we set out to do which is
begin our dough next we're gonna kind of
need everything together everyone has
strengths and weaknesses
for me strength incredible masterful
wordplay and multitasking weakness
making pasta wells next we're gonna
start to knead our dough together your
domain to require a lot of attention but
sometimes it's okay to be needy ah tough
stuff there we go all right voila now
that you've got your dough made and
smoothed out it's time to set it aside
in your bowl take a tiny towel and let
your dough have a tiny 30-minute nap and
now it's time to roll out our ravioli oh
hello little dough baby so cute and
smooth now let's slice it and now it
sliced down the center boom yes now
we're gonna take our favorite you'll be
the one to start and place all the rest
to the side now we're gonna flour our
surface and then we're gonna start our
ravioli roll it's okay to put a little
flour on your rolling pin too and we
roll
give it one last little roll and then
set your rolling pin aside now in this
recipe it doesn't call for exact
measurements thank God I got these
chestnuts here so I can know how much
half is and our little ravioli stamp
it's about the size of it chestnut what
an accurate analogy mmm I love a
chestnut oh sorry did you want to keep
learning about ravioli my bad now I
tried to call my blacksmith to have him
custom make me a ravioli cutter Bonnie
was a little busy this weekend so
instead we're using this one for our
first batch we're gonna cut out 15
little ravioli shapes 1tu 15 you might
notice that these ravioli are pretty
tiny especially when you consider we're
gonna fold them in half but remember
these weren't dishes that were being
made to enjoy for dinner at home these
were dishes that were made to be enjoyed
as part of a banquet tons of tiny little
foods and snacks each announced by
trumpet imagine if we did that today
every time we left the kitchen I have
pizza bites actually I'm going to start
doing that every time I walk out of the
kitchen now that we have our tiny
raviolis cut out it's time to get even
tinier by adding a quarter teaspoon of
our filling remember how much filling we
have this is a quarter teaspoon look at
that that's nothing okay this one's
ready to go let's set it down and keep
going
looking at how small these are I can see
why they made them by the hundreds but I
can also see why I don't want to now
it's time to fold and pinch our ravioli
we're gonna take our egg wash do a
little teeny tiny baby dollop pick up
our teeny-tiny ravioli and pinch it
closed and voila a single itty bitty
tiny ravioli my hands are small people I
think this is about the size of half a
quarter or dare I say half a chestnut
and fifteen Wow
now it's time to take these baby ravioli
and boil them in our broth I'm just
gonna put them on my pocket now it's
time to cook our pasta we're gonna be
boiling our ravioli in our broth of Cape
on so this is the same broth that we use
to get our Cape on breast earlier mmm
rustic next we're going to be adding our
saffron whoo now our ravioli the recipe
doesn't call out any standard units of
measurement for time instead it says let
them boil for the time it takes to say
to pattern oysters good thing I have it
right here
pattern oh s--- turkey essence Ellis
sank defect sitter nomen tuum adveniat
regnum tuum we know we're not casting a
spell or anything right
round two our ravioli are done look
they're floating I mean that's just
nifty we're gonna fish him out put him
in our little plate I can't get over how
accurate that was this guy really knew
his stuff ladle in a little extra broth
because you don't want to miss out on
this and last but not least we add our
sweet spices of cinnamon and sugar and
then top it with some parmesan because
nothing says delicious like rooster
broth cinnamon sugar and Parmesan
[Music]
ravioli is
now it's time to taste our cinnamon a
sugary ravioli meat soup buon appetito
[Music]
hmm hmm hmm okay good news
the ravioli itself fantastic the filling
is actually really lovely the mint the
mincemeat it goes together great this
broth however is just like a melted
parmesan salt soup so I would say maybe
go a little easy on the broth in short I
think we've learned that when it comes
to making ravioli the possibilities are
endless thanks so much for watching this
episode of edible history would you try
this ravioli at home let us know in the
comments below and be sure to come back
for more episodes of your new favorite
show this one bye